[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEN TONG: Ready to get
going with another talk?
OK, in this talk, we
are going to be building
a universal translator
with Firebase
and Google Cloud Platform
in front of your very eyes.
Sound like a plan?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JEN TONG: Cool.
And it takes three of us to do
it, to build an app altogether.
So I'm going to be doing
a lot of the talking
and some of the coding.
I'm Jen.
And joining me is--
Hi, Hi, I'm Kathy.
BRET MCGOWEN: I'm Brett.
JEN TONG: Cool.
And we are going to get
going in just a minute.
But before we do that,
let me tell you a story,
because everybody likes
story time, right?
I like story time.
And I'm going to tell
you a story about science
fiction, because I love sci-fi.
Are there any other sci-fi
fans in the audience?
Yay!
Sci-fi is great.
And one of my favorite science
fiction shows is "Star Trek."
And one of the things that
makes "Star Trek" so awesome
is all of the different
technology that's in the show.
For example, you
have the captain,
who can ask a computer with
his own voice for a cup of tea,
and the computer will respond
by making it magically appear.
And although we can't make
tea appear from air yet,
we're actually
making good progress
on a lot of "Star
Trek" technology.
You can talk to a computer with
things like Google Assistant,
and it can understand you
and comprehend your question
and come up with
a great response.
Another really cool
technology from "Star Trek"
was the universal
translator, which
I think it was more
of just convenience
to make the plots
easier to write,
that the way team would beam
down on some foreign world
and encounter some alien race
they had never seen before,
and within the first
couple words they muttered,
they were instantly able
to communicate perfectly.
And it was really cool.
In fact, that is
the technology I
would love to have today because
I travel around a little bit
to do things like give talks.
But I'm one of those
monolingual people.
I can only speak one language.
I'm ashamed.
And it would be great
if I could communicate
with people in their preferred
language more easily.
So we're going to
solve that problem
today using the technique we
use to solve all of the problems
in our life, which is software.
Specifically, we're going
to build mobile apps.
But we want to be able
to work with everybody,
whether they have a
specific preferred language
or a specific preferred
mobile platform.
So we want this app to
work on iOS and Android.
And this is where
Firebase comes in.
Whereas traditionally, if
we wanted to build an app
that allowed us to communicate
between different platforms
and do it in a hurry,
we'd have some challenges,
because we'd probably want to
spin up a big old cluster--
maybe a Redis here,
maybe a PostgreSQL there,
a whole bunch of Compute
Engine instances--
and probably wire those
into some cool backend APIs
to take up some of
the heavy lifting.
But we don't have time
for that, so we want
to take a different approach.
And this is where Firebase can
help us get a lot of motion
really quickly.
Firebase gives us both--
in addition to all sorts
of cool backend stuff,
also gives us a whole
bunch of client libraries
and easy bindings
to those components
to make it easier than ever
to build stuff rapidly.
One way I like to
think about Firebase
is, it is my biggest bag
of app development goodies.
So it has all sorts of things
to make my web and mobile app
development easier.
It has things like
authentication helpers,
and static file hosting,
and deep dynamic links,
and crash reporting.
And I could wax on about
this stuff for a long time.
But we only have
20-something minutes left,
so we're just going
to focus on a few
of these different goodies.
We're going to talk about
Cloud storage for Firebase.
authentication and the Realtime
Database.
So let's dig into each one
of these little bit deeper.
First, Cloud storage
for Firebase--
a lot of modern
applications have
to move binary chunks of
stuff around, like files.
You might have to upload
photos, or in our case,
we might have some
recorded audio
that we want to move around.
And Firebase for
Cloud storage makes
this a lot easier because
it gives you cool client
library stuff that
allows you to not
have to think much about it.
You just send off your
blob of data into the sky,
and then all of
your other clients
can automatically get that
access to that binary data
really easily.
And it takes advantage of all
of the cool infrastructure
that Google provides--
its super-fast network,
high reliability, all
that stuff that's really
a pain to build on your own.
So now we have all of our
binary stuff dealt with.
Next, we want to
handle authentication.
And authentication
is an important thing
that's useful for many
different applications.
You always want to know
who's doing an action so you
can control access to data.
But in the case of
this application,
we just want to
control it little bit.
We want to make sure
that only those of us
onstage can write data into
our universal translator,
because we know some
of you might want
to play some trickery on us.
So we're going to use
Firebase Auth for that.
And has anybody ever rolled
their own authentication
from scratch?
No one?
A couple people.
It's really kind of a
pain, whether you're
doing email and password
login and then you
have to make sure you're
doing the right hashing
on those passwords, or if
you're integrating with an OAuth
provider from Google or
Facebook, there's a lot of work
there that we seem to do
over and over and over again.
And it never gets more fun.
And that's where
Firebase Authentication
takes a lot of the
heavy parts of that
and just gives you easy
binding to the client
libraries so you can
get authentication done
and move on with your app.
And one of the cool
things about Firebase Auth
is that even if you
support multiple different
authentication providers, like
email and Twitter and Facebook,
all of your users still
have a single identifier
that you can use to identify
them across your application.
So we have authentication taken
care of and the binary object
stuff.
This is where my
favorite part of Firebase
comes in-- the
Realtime Database.
It is awesome.
And this is how it works.
So it is like a big old
ball of JSON in the sky,
because we like JSON, right?
It's great.
What do you do is, you take
any of your data that you could
represent as JSON-- so
text, booleans, numbers,
that kind of stuff--
and you have all your clients
write to different locations
on this big old tree of JSON.
And then this is where
the magic comes in,
because instead of your other
clients explicitly reading
a location and having to
deal with all that network
asynchronous stuff, what
the Firebase clients allow
you to do is just have your
clients tell Firebase what node
or what subtree, or even
a query against a subtree,
in that JSON blob
that they care about.
And then the client
libraries take
care of calling your function
whenever there's a change.
And we also take care
of all that hard stuff--
like cache invalidation and
handling online and offline
network blips--
handles all of that for you.
And it's awesome.
So I could talk about this
stuff for a long time,
but you're here to
see some code, right?
We're going to build
the apps right now.
And I'm going to
hand it over to Brat,
who's going to help guide us
through the coding process.
And we're going to go
to the coding view now.
BRET MCGOWEN: All
right, thank you, Jen.
So not only are we going to
live code an app in front of you
today, we're actually going
to live code two apps.
So we have Kathy here.
She's going to be working
on the iOS version.
And we have Jen,
who's going to be
working on the Android version.
So let's get started.
So let's talk a little bit
about what this app looks
like from a UI perspective.
What are the pieces?
So we've got a language picker.
This is going to set
the language that's
my preferred language.
This will both be the language
that I'm speaking into the app,
and it's also the language
that I will hear spoken back
to me as messages come in.
So again, messages can be
coming in from any language
and their point of origin,
but when it gets to me,
it'll be translated out loud
into my preferred language.
So the way that
you'll do this is,
you'll hit the Record button.
It will create an audio
file local on your device.
And what we will code
up in front of you
is how to upload that to the
Cloud, do the processing,
and return the translation back.
So let's dive right
into the code.
We've actually
preconfigured these apps.
Not only did we flesh
out the UI already,
we've also used Gradle
and CocoaPods to set up
Firebase for Android
and iOS, respectively.
So the first thing
we need to do is
connect to our three services.
So we're going to create an
instance to the Firebase Auth
service, the Firebase
Realtime Database
service, and the
Firebase Storage service.
Once we have those
references, we're
actually going to prep some
data, including the file
to be uploaded, before we
actually do the upload.
So we're going to
get two references.
One is where we're going to
upload this file into Cloud
storage-- what location--
which would be under uploads,
and then also where in the
database, the Firebase Realtime
Database, we're going to write
this data, which would also
be under the uploads
node in the database.
We're going to
set some metadata.
Specifically, we'll set
the audio file type.
So it'll be AMR for Android
and it'll be Linear 16 for iOS.
So once we have that
data set, let's actually
perform the upload.
So we're going to use
Firebase's putFile method, which
gives us a few event listeners.
The first listener will
respond to its failure.
So in case something
goes wrong, we're
going to show the user a toast--
wah, wah, your upload failed.
And in the case
of success, we'll
have a listener that will take
some metadata-- specifically,
the type of encoding,
the language of origin,
and the location
in Cloud storage--
and we're going to write that to
the Firebase Realtime Database.
And because we're writing
it to the Realtime Database,
this will enable all of our
clients to, in realtime,
get updates when
something happens.
So that's actually all
the code that we need.
We are able to upload the file
and write it to the database.
So let's see a demo.
So if we fire this up in the
emulator, and once it loads--
all right, let's
see, let's try iOS.
Kathy, do you want
to say something?
KATHY LI: Yeah.
So I've selected my
language picker to English,
and I'm going to
make a recording.
Hello, world.
BRET MCGOWEN: All right.
KATHY LI: Oh, no.
So it says, failed
to upload audio
with a 403 permission denied.
BRET MCGOWEN: OK, so our
first demo failure of the day.
Actually not, this is good.
It's the rare case
where we actually
want to see this error message.
And that's because we
have no authentication,
and our Firebase storage, our
Cloud storage, is secured.
So there's two ways we
can get around this error.
The first, which I
know a lot of you do,
is you just open
it up for everyone
and just let anyone
in the internet read
and write to your
storage bucket.
That's super easy,
and that's not
what we're going to do today.
So we'll actually
show you how easy
it is to do the correct way,
which is to put authentication
onto your app so that
you can make sure
that not any schmuck
on the internet
is uploading audio files.
What could possibly go wrong?
So the first thing we'll
do is, we will set up
the off flow,
which is basically,
is the user already
authenticated or not?
And if they're
not authenticated,
we're going to use something
called Firebase UI, which
is an open source library that
has entire social flows for all
of your providers, like Google,
Twitter, Facebook, email,
and so forth.
So not just the backend and
the managing of the tokens
and the OAuth, but
actually UI, out-of-the-box
that's configurable, so you can
get an out-of-the-box UI with
very minimal effort.
So now that we actually have
that authentication working,
let's try our demo again.
And hopefully, we'll get
a little better result.
So really, with just
a few lines of code,
we're enabling authentication
with Google or with email.
So--
KATHY LI: So now I'll
sign in as prompted,
and once I've signed in,
make another recording.
Hello, awesome developers.
BRET MCGOWEN: All right.
And hopefully,
uploaded-- positive.
All right, awesome.
So cool.
Thank you, Kathy.
Now, to prove that
that wasn't a trick,
that we actually did an upload--
so Jen has got the
console here in Firebase,
so she's showing the
Firebase Realtime Database.
And you can see that it has
some data about the file we just
uploaded, like the encoding
type, the file type, and also
the location in Cloud storage.
So let's actually go to
Cloud storage and see
the file that we just created
when Kathy recorded her voice.
So we'll actually download this
to Jen's local workstation.
And we'll put it into
our audio player,
and so you can
actually hear Kathy's--
maybe.
KATHY LI (RECORDING):
Hello, awesome developers.
BRET MCGOWEN: All
right, cool, awesome.
Yes.
[LAUGHS]
[APPLAUSE]
So we're actually almost there.
So we've got the final recording
and uploading successfully.
There's only one
more thing we need
to add to our client, which
is when a translation happens,
we need to actually
display that in the client,
and then play the text out loud.
So let's do that now.
If we pop back
over into our code,
we're going to do
a couple of things.
We're going to connect to the
Firebase Realtime Database.
And once we do that, we're going
to listen on the translations
node in the JSON tree.
So the way the
data is structured,
we've got a translation node.
And every time a new phrase
or whatever comes in,
it gets a new child
node under that.
And then under that,
there's a list of languages.
And it's all asynchronous.
So as they're
getting translated,
asynchronously, it's populating
that node when it's finished,
if that make sense.
So Hindi finishes
first, and maybe English
comes in second, and then
French, and so forth.
So what we're
actually going to do
is have a listener for when
a new translation comes in,
and then we're going to
have a second listener just
on the language
we're interested in.
So that way, if we're
listening for English
and it gets finished
first, then our app
will get updated right
away without having
to wait for all the other
languages to finish,
because we don't
care about those
for our particular client.
And once we have
that finished, we're
going to take the text that
comes back from Firebase--
it'll have been
pre-translated-- and we're
going to pipe it to our
update and play method here
in our apps, which
actually uses text
to speech within the Android and
iOS app to play that out loud.
So I think those
are all the pieces.
Let's actually load
up the demo again.
And so the piece we
don't have yet is
the part that actually takes
the audio file, listens to it,
turns it into text,
and then translate that
into another language.
Well, we actually do
have that technology,
and that is called Jen.
So we've got some
Jen-powered translation.
You've heard of
test-driven development,
this is Jen-driven
translation, JDT.
And so what Jen is going
to do is manually listen
to that audio file, go
into the Firebase Database,
add a child under the
translations object,
and put in her desired
translation in English,
for this case.
And so as soon as
that's done, you
can see it actually
shows up already
onto Kathy's iOS device.
So as far as I'm
concerned, actually,
we have all the
pieces we need, right?
We've got audio files
recording, they're uploading,
we've got Jen doing the
listening in the translation.
As far as I know,
everything is good.
But I sleep sometimes?
Oh, so that's a problem.
So if you need any
translation between the hours
of 11:00 PM and 7:00 AM,
unfortunately, our service
would be offline.
If only there were
some buzzword we
could add to serverless that
would do some of this for us,
maybe something like
machine learning.
Let's bring Kathy out.
And Kathy is going to talk
to us about how we can solve
this using machine learning.
Welcome, Kathy.
KATHY LI: Thanks, Bret.
So to avoid the problem of Jen
having to manually translate
all of our recordings,
we're going to instead plug
in some software.
And while it would
be a cool project
to design and train our own
machine learning models, that
would take longer than we want
now, as we want to quickly
get this app up and running.
So that's where we go to
Google Cloud Platform's machine
learning pre-trained
machine learning APIs.
And there are a set of different
APIs to solve common use cases,
such as image recognition.
And in this case, we'll pick
the two that work for our app.
So we'll be using the Cloud
Speech API to transcribe
audio recordings into text,
and then the Cloud Translation
API to translate text among
all the different languages.
So now, do we have all the
components to make our app
work?
Seems like it.
We're almost there,
except how are we
going to wire these cool Cloud
APIs into our serverless app?
Traditionally,
with Firebase apps,
you would bake everything
into the client,
which is great and convenient
because it's serverless.
But we do run into
a few challenges
here that many apps will
come across as they scale.
For example, your app
may have some secrets.
In our case, we
have API keys that
will be used with
those two cloud APIs,
and you may have
some pre-release,
like feature-flagged code
packaged with your app that is
possibly discoverable by users.
Also, we may have some logic
that's resource-intensive.
Our end users'
devices could have
their battery drained
quickly by performing
all these translations.
And so we don't want that.
And building mobile
applications across platforms
often requires writing
logic multiple times,
and we would prefer to
avoid that, if possible.
So our app has all
of these challenges,
but we can mitigate them
by moving our API secrets
and resource-intensive
code into the Cloud, where
we can write the translation
logic once and have it work
for our Android and iOS apps.
What might that actually
look like, though?
We might think
first of something
like this, where you spin up
some compute instances that
will serve your APIs.
But there's actually
some complexity to that.
As you scale, you'll have
to deal with load balancing,
caching, routing requests to
your various microservices.
And soon, you may end up
actually managing something
that looks like this, which is
more complexity than we'd like.
However, at Google,
we've been helping
to manage your app architecture
stress for a long time.
Google Cloud platform
actually started
with App Engine in 2008, the
original platform as a service.
And while a lot has
changed since then,
we've built on our
decade of experience
providing compute
solutions for your apps
to deliver the right
solution for our use case.
So now, instead of
this, we'll actually
use Cloud Functions,
which will serve
as the glue for
our serverless app.
And now we have
a new recipe that
looks like this, where we'll
put our API keys into our Cloud
functions, and any
other secrets have
that drive, the
resource-intensive computation.
And then we can write
the functions once,
and have them execute the
logic for both mobile apps.
So now Brett will show us
what writing these Cloud
Functions actually looks like.
To get started with
Cloud Functions,
unlike writing a mobile app,
it's actually pretty simple.
We have, initially, a
few variables up top
that include our credentials for
using the Cloud APIs, as well
as a function stub here.
Then we'll start with our
first Cloud Function, which
you specify the trigger that
invokes the function, which,
in this case, would be a new
upload of the audio recording
to the Firebase
Realtime Database.
And we listen on
the uploads node.
And when we get a new
upload in that subtree,
then we'll pull some
metadata from it,
such as the language
that the recording was in
and the encoding
and sample rate,
and then make a call
to the Cloud Speech API
to get the transcript
of the text.
And we send along the
location in Cloud storage
of the actual binary
data, the audio recording.
And when we get
back the transcript,
we'll write it back to
the Realtime Database
under transcripts to set us
up for the next part, which
is translation.
And for translation, we'll
create a second Cloud Function,
this time listening
on the translations
subtree in our
Realtime Database.
And upon getting a new
transcript written,
we'll take that and iterate
through all the languages
that our app supports,
and for each language,
make a call to the
Cloud translation API,
get the translation, and
write it back to our Realtime
Database under translations.
And at the end, having
processed all our languages,
we'll signal that the
function is complete.
So actually, at this point,
we have all the logic
we need to make our app work.
And all we have
left is to deploy
the functions, which is
pretty straightforward.
With a Firebase
deploy command, you
can deploy all the
functions you've written.
And it might take
a couple minutes.
And we have precious time here,
so we've done the deployment.
This is what it looks like.
And now I'll hand
it back to Jen,
who will show us what
the working translation
app looks like.
JEN TONG: Thanks.
So this is where I
need all of your help,
those of you here in
person and those of you
on the internet via
the live stream.
I know all of you have some kind
of computing device with you,
and many of those
contain web browsers.
I want you all to go to this
URL on your computing thing.
And then if you want
to be extra awesome,
turn your volume up a little
bit, maybe all the way.
I promise there won't be a
Rickroll or anything like that.
But we want all of you to
participate in our demo
and help us test our app.
So-- oops-- we are
going to go back over
to see our app with
everything together.
So I'm going to switch
on over to the one that's
wired up to the Cloud
Functions, and we're
going to give it a spin.
And I mentioned before that
I'm a monolingual person,
but I'm going to do my
best attempt at speaking
another language and see
if we can use this app
to translate this
message to all of you
and my peers on the stage.
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
There's my terrible attempt
at a foreign language.
Let's see if it does stuff.
So it's uploaded, and
now it's up in the Cloud
doing the translation.
And--
COMPUTER: Good morning, baby.
JEN TONG: So I hear it
muttering many languages about.
If we switch over to English, we
can see, "Good morning, baby."
OK, so my Japanese
is not that good.
But would anyone like
to give me a reply
in a different language?
KATHY LI: I do have a
response for you, Jen.
And actually, I will switch
the language picker over
to yet another language.
And here we go.
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
So the function
should be triggering.
COMPUTER: In fact,
it's the afternoon now.
JEN TONG: In fact, it
is the afternoon now.
Yes, it is, but I only know how
to say good morning, kind of,
in Japanese.
That's about as close as
we can get for the demo.
So I heard a lot of other
people in the audience using it,
and I heard a lot of syllables,
phonemes, and languages
I don't understand.
How did it translate?
Did anybody try a language
other than English, French,
or Japanese?
How did it work?
Did it translate successfully?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
JEN TONG: Kind of?
OK, kind of, kind of.
I hear a lot of this going on.
Well, it's our first rev and we
built it in about 20 minutes,
so we'll fix all of that
in the next version.
But I think it's time for
us to start to wrap up.
So let's take a peek at what
we all did over the last 20
minutes or so.
So we went in with a
plan to help us translate
and more easily communicate
with people all over the world.
And we accomplished
it how we solve
all of our
accomplishments, how we
solve all of our problems in
life, by writing mobile apps.
And we wrote two apps.
We wrote an Android app.
We wrote an iOS app.
And then once those
were built, we also
built out a backend to
connect those all together
and to connect them
into third-party APIs.
So whereas in the past,
we might have ended up
building something like
this, which we could not
have possibly done in
a half-hour session,
but we have a new arrow in
our quiver with Firebase.
We're able to
connect the signaling
between the mobile apps together
using the Firebase client
libraries and backend
services, and then
take it a step further
with Cloud Functions.
And this allows us
to take advantage
of all of the cool
stuff that Firebase
has to offer and easily
connect into all sorts
of other third-party APIs out
there, whether they be APIs
from Google Cloud
Platform or APIs
from other vendors or
your own home-brew APIs.
It's a great glue for
a lot of your projects.
So here's where I have a
challenge for all of you.
Hopefully, you have another
arrow in your app dev quiver
that you can use to solve
all of your app dev problems.
So I want all of you to go out
there and try and build stuff
with this formula.
And I want you to tell us
about what you've built,
because we love
hearing from you.
So go ahead, build stuff, and
then let us know how it goes.
So we love to hear from you
about questions, concerns,
and just awesome stuff
you want to share.
Here are our Twitter handles.
We love hearing from you.
DMs are definitely welcome.
And of course, getting
a little meta here,
we love feedback on
our sessions, as well.
So please go ahead and scan
this QR code or go to the URL
at the bottom of
the page and let
us know what you
thought of the session.
And with that, thank
you all very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]